There are plenty of examples of what not to do in a lot of these films.
*epic inspirational trumpet*
*hissing*
In my line of work you run into snakes fairly often
And you do have to be careful. You know snakes will come cruising through an archeological site and some people freak out, and I run after it and catch it.
And come back and freak people out a little more.
A lot of the destruction of antiquities that happens in many of the different films is something that we really try to avoid.
He is not patient. He's not patient at all and archeology is a science of incredible patience.
The opening of the Ark of the Covenant is not something you would do lightly.
So that's very impatient.
I know people who have had to shoot it out with bandits. Who've had graduate students kidnapped.
I know people who have been kidnapped and assaulted, and when they start shooting you shoot back.
Nothing shocks me. I'm a scientist.
There is kind of rush that you get when you're holding an artifact that no ones seen or touched in thousands of years. It is quite thrilling.
I was a little let down by Kingdom of the Crystal Skull. First of all there are no known civilizations like that in South America.
A lot of the crystal skulls that we know of appear to have been manufactured in the modern era.
The first one is the best in the series, I think. I like the third one too. And hopefully number five will be even better.
*epic inspiring trumpet*